hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a CP
containment breach Oh eyes oh you know
for a second there I was almost happy
and like oh I get to play a video game
again and I then I thought I remembered
what game I was playing so let's just um
let's just carry on whoa whoa hey hey I
see you down there
don't you look so cute haha with your
evilness help everyone like the question
posed on the Facebook okay so I can't
quite contain him just yet
and this guy's zipping around down there
i I don't wait was it two of them oh he
moved okay haha house Oh God
okay I'm gonna leave before he decides
to come up here screw that and
everything about that screw all of that
exactly every of that while I carry on
and go down one of these doors over here
now my objective for this playthrough is
to try and find a new ending okay I
could summon radical Larry if I went in
here is if you go to the coffin he pops
up out of the ground in front of the
coffin not that he is that SCPD just
doesn't don't know why oh yeah
SCP blah blah blah one seven three comes
in here
and hey buddy hey buddy okay so what is
this note I don't remember seeing that
okay a tactical squadron unit deployed
in the rare case of an XK or CKD class
end of the world scenario most notably
in a site-wide containment breach and
the subsequent loss of several euclid or
Keter class SCPs
most noteworthy about epsilon11 is its
sparse number of specialists among its
division from which it in is its
namesake nonetheless each R of the nine
personnel are veteran in their field of
work and are highly regarded amongst the
many MTF groups ok so basically that's
the group of people that come in and try
to eradicate everyone in here after [ __ ]
goes down and [ __ ] most certainly does
down oh I love it when the doors are
already open for me makes me feel so
assured that things are gonna be alright
oh no I know it doesn't it makes me feel
like I'm gonna die whatever I'm braver
than this I couldn't take them won 7-3
ain't got nothing on my swagger
oh hello hey look it's the computer room
let's go pay him a visit not that I
don't think I don't think he's gonna do
anything until I turn off the power wait
a minute what is there always a right
turn after that no this is different
Oh different let me hang on I got
dropped some stuff anyway don't need
that don't need that don't need that I
never did finish reading d 9 3 4 1 d 9 3
4 ok whatever it's really dark in here
what hi oh yeah oh hey well hi let me
through haha [ __ ] what you got now
computer uh what what you staring at me
huh you loser huh
you're just a nerd a geeky nerd there's
one seven three zooming around yeah yeah
is good for him okay so I can't do
anything until get to where I need to be
now let me out let me out oh man thank
you okay I need to UM first turn off the
power before I can talk to him but maybe
I don't want to talk to him because he's
the one that let me out of gate B which
is how the first ending went when I
played through this before
won 7-3 appears to be zooming around so
I'm gonna close this door
what was he right there was that him
those ham wasn't it that's how you man
is much more persistent I swear I've
never seen him this tractive okay I'm
a-goin here got some a dot sdp 4:23 brah
brah and now I'm gonna get in a really
good habit of closing doors behind me I
see man yeah I'm good now yeah ma'am
ma'am
okay so then nothing for that in this
room there was a piece of paper in here
before don't know what happened to it
though this nuclear device ah I wonder
if this has to do with the other ending
because if I actually set off the
nuclear little eyes then maybe I don't
know no I don't know I'm thinking that
the ending has to do with that a nuclear
detonation I don't know though I just
don't know what happens if you like
smoke 420 J right in front of scp-173
would it change anything would it just
be a stupid thing to do crazy but no ha
okay here's the tunnel what do I need
from the tunnel is blue blue blue blue
blue blue no okay so I don't need that
don't need that don't need to go in the
tunnel this yet I'm still an exploratory
mode explored ah ha ah yeah I saw you I
saw you
I tell you I tell you hey buddy while
you're being a dick can you go away Oh
gimme pardon me yuck
dammit he's in my way this is my way
well loser this guy is well what an ugly
son of a [ __ ]
when ugly [ __ ] never really got a
good look at his face before why would
you go
yeah man you are weird is that on your
face looks like y'all
way big blink I'm blinking over here now
I'm blinky over here good you booth
thank you oh oh you do far oh god oh god
I'm almost out of link juice come over
turn around I know you can open the door
you dick
I know oh maybe not you but the computer
can if the computer decides to be an
[ __ ] all right I'm trusting you
Jojo top ahead I'm gonna connect screw
you everything you I [ __ ] ash Nikes ha
ha ha
what who's that who's that one was that
one with that what would that what was
that what was that holy baloney what was
that hey buddy give me give me
I've got other problems to deal with I
have other pressing matters to deal with
I guess I can go down the tunnel because
the tunnel will lead if I can get past
radical area and go the other end of the
tunnel which means that I'll be able to
get to another area of the facility I
will need the gas masks in order to run
as quick as possible what's that what's
that the little creature that darts out
of your vision I don't know remember
what SCP that is I've got a stick it
dark Oh God really dark it's really dark
Oh God dark it's dark it's so dark it's
soda oh my god I'm all right
oh shut up
it's much darker than it used to be
where the hell am I pitch blackness I
can't see anything
I'm just running oh god I'm gonna die
I'm gonna die I'm not gonna die
obviously I cannot see anything it's
pitch blackness can't must take off ah
open open I need to be logged dig dig
dig dig Oh God
it's all something oh my gosh no no
under fair
that's not fair that's not fair me and
okay I'll get the bird no while I'm in
here why can i still hear them from in
here that shouldn't be where's the note
where's the note where's it no oh there
it is okay last one I look okay ernõ got
it let's go let's go baby let's go
can't read that ah oh you oh I thought
you fixed that problem the damn fall
through the floor glitchy glitchy even I
thought you fix a problem dammit tablet
tablet sorry about this guy's there are
obviously a still a few bugs
the problem is when when it ports you
around in his world sometimes it'll drop
you through the floor and that's still a
problem because everything will be
looong ki-woo blue one cleat trademark
trademark Marga bar will be Lou Wong
Healy you can't be willy wonka lee
without paying me a nickel personnel are
made aware of possible rays tears of him
okay alright so anyway I turned right I
would have found a yeah I would have
found the burn note right away right
right right where the hell is it thing
oh don't tell me okay there so I'm not
gonna go down that one because that
would be smart
don't be woolly luckily Pama where am I
whoa vodka what happened where am I
what's going on what is happening where
are my wolf what doesn't know Oh balls
Bologna everything's just really dark I
mean it back before it was a lot
brighter for some reason and now things
it things is dark yo things is dark oh
man I don't know if they added anything
in radical Larry's pocket dimension but
I'm gonna be here for day ah ah what do
whoa what did happen well just happen
what does happen
I'm gonna be here for days all huh I
wonder if there's a time letter if I
just wander around here for - ah yes I'm
out I'm in radical Larry's place and I
have the ability to contain him to
contain him alright so there's the guy
got turn the see this off this on this
on hello hi hello hi
please let me go no I don't think so
hello sound transmission I thought that
was the femur breaker here we go
that's
I still feel really bad about that
we were the voice actor that did that
voice did a really good job
okay so after he's contained I got to
turn up this back on this
right right and now he is contained
before I don't need a level four I need
a level 15 bajillion which I have here
okay
so is the security task force here yet
they were here last time I popped out I
got shot in the face all right go
mission accomplished
radical larry is contained and I am
moving forward with rapid something I
don't know
rapid success I don't know okay so yes
his new chamber is floating up in the
air it's maglev contained or whatnot
sound transmission is off he is good we
are good we get the burnt note so when
we come across dr. Maynard office
hopefully it'll actually work this time
let us through still don't know who I
need to go down there
hi buddy hi how you doing friend Heidi
unfriendly yeah good yeah I'm gonna end
the sub sub right where I started it I
hear with the anomalous duck so hope you
all enjoyed this one this game is this
game is awful but this game is great and
at the same time so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that I've done and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye II
loud enough free
are you
Oh
maybe